moi je ne pense pas qu'en pensent les
mois autour de la table oui non non non
non il n'ya qu'un seul oui c'est
jean-michel on va on va se réserver au
phare est la vie unique sur ce plateau
maxime c'est une économie importante
un rayonnement international
et pour info paris est la seule et
unique ville dans le monde de la haute
couture donc franchement si léo les
effets des cils et des bilans si cher
c'est aussi pour mettre en valeur tout
le travail de ce qu'on appelle dans la
bonne les petites mains à savoir les
boutonnières les couturières les
plumassière est bon ce sont des métiers
magnifique tonkov bravo à eux d'être
aussi mises en valeur sur des défilés
qui font rêver et ce don par maxime on a
des chiffres il y a seulement 2200
couturière qualifiés dans le monde pour
travailler dans la haute couture sur
toute la terre entière seul rêve sont
seulement 2200 seuls 4000 femmes peuvent
se payer les tenues d'autres couture et
entre 1000 et 6000 heures sont
nécessaires pour réaliser une robe de
haute couture à ce stade la ccl dollar
j'adore mais c'est ça c'est exactement
cela un spectacle pour moi fin si ce
geste est juste incroyable de voir
autant d'énergie pour quelques minutes
de show moi ça me fait rêver ça me
passionne c'est comme quand j'ai dans
les musées pour moi c'est pareil c'est
artistique il faut être sensible après
vous l'êtes peut-être pas sensible à cet
art je te comprendre aussi simplement
mersen moi ça me fait rêver et je ses
droits il ya un préservatif ont tué pour
moi j'ai fait ça quand j'étais jeune je
l'aimé pas d'accord non plus n'ont en
fait cela je pensais de la question
c'est est faut-il boycotter la
fashion-week donc pour servir eux-mêmes
moi je la boycotte déjà pourtant j'aime
bien tout ce qui est sap la mode etc
mais en fait je comprends plus projet ta
90% des marques on les connaît pas les
10% que connaît personne n'a les moyens
de s'acheter ses marques là à part des
fois on sait des petits plaisirs mais
ainsi qu'ils ont les moyens s'acheter
ses marques là ils les achètent pas qui
a par lady gaga va acheter une robe en
forme de viande ou de cartons personnes
s'est pas fait pour ça la bandoulière du
coup là jean michel vous êtes tous
d'accord avec mon tiroir d'accord c'est
un spectacle est réservé à une élite
oula kaka pays on puisse parfois 7000 ou
10000 euros assisté c'est indigne
franchement pour assister aux besoins
des gens il est sûr on
69ème à le coût des filets les décors
peuvent aller jusqu'à 5 millions d'euros
pour juste un défilé des choses que ça
entre 9000 et un million d'euros c'est
complètement dingue voit même pas
une boule de malabar mais c'est vrai que
là c'est la performance et de l'art et
que c'était un petit peu
incompréhensible il ya eu quand même un
petit problème de timing c'est vrai
puisque la fashion weeks c'était juste
là là et avec la guerre en ukraine
c'était un petit peu compliqué c'est à
dire qu'on voyait à la fois pareil défi
de l'est aussi sur les podiums quand on
voyait aussi des filles de l'est qui
allait se réfugier pour quitter mes
craintes étaient un petit peu compliqué
en terme de timing en revanche il ya eu
beaucoup beaucoup de participation des
grands groupes par exemple le groupe
kering avec balenciaga et là c'est un
peu ce
que nos élèves ont joué oui génial
les performances avec cette finale
s'est disputée il n'y a pas que ça que
ça qu'on retient ce qui peut faire le
bien
mais c'est très bien de faire le buzz
justement ça leur a permis de faire des
dons et s'était alors dit assez bon
résumé tout l'argent au dessin 3 tous
les cas c'est ce qu'ils ont fait savoir
que le gouvernement allemand d'argent
c'est une image et une économie qui
fonctionne tous les fashionistas du
monde entier qui viennent à paris bah ça
remplit les restaurants ça remplit
nouveau look ça remplit nos musées mais
je suis désolé c'est important de faire
musées le musée belge espère bien très
bien à moi je pense que absolument pas
il faut pas la boycotter et là où je
trouve qu'on est très démago des très
démagogue parce qu'en fait tous les
vêtements comporte la actuellement sont
inspirés par la passeuse par le courage
de défricheur de jihlava smash inspire
réellement de la fashion week et
concrètement là je trouve ça très
démagogue et en plus de ça c'est de
l'art en fête la grecque la viande de
l'ars c'est de la technicité et tout ce
qu'ils sont en train de faire c'est
vraiment de la technicité ya énormément
de personnes qui travaillent sur une
seule oeuvre l'année ça fait énormément
travaillé donc non tous les gens qui
nous regardent porte mes vêtements de
mode concrètement les l'amazone oui
parce que la fashion week c'est
l'inspiration ça inspire la fast fashion
ce qui est vraiment problématique en
fait c'est les personnes qui regardent
cette fashion week en se pensant qu'il
faut être supérieur qu'il faut être
résolus
et ce monde là qui est problématique
comme série q que son problème direct
coco chanel par exemple alizés cohérence
et la beauté c'est être franc même tout
simplement
et jusque là je suis d'accord avec toi
sur la mode mais passons la fashion-week
parce que ce qu'ils en ont fait comme il
a dit c'est la course au buzz au jour
d'aujourd'hui on se rappelle de quoi on
se rappelle de zahia qui marchait comme
un crabe là à cause de sa robe c'est à
dire la retenue quoi on a retenu jusque
rihanna s'est pointé à poil d'ailleurs
j'ai pas compris son projet elle je la
presse en plus elle a de l'argent - mais
c'est un truc de fou est en fait la
forme elle a pris le dessus sur le fond
si si tu ajoutes à ça les problèmes
écologiques ben franchement non moi je
suis pas pour la vie privée quand même
parce que ça fait partie de la culture
de l'histoire de la france mais la
boycotter dans l'état je suis prêt mais
fashion week automne gens qui ont besoin
de s'habiller catch et on est beaux
vêtements les gorges chaudes ultime des
beaux métiers qui donc travaillent pour
approfondir ce débat on vous a préparé
un top du meilleur et du pire de la
fashion week des vidéos parfois très
drôles parfois gênant parfois
spectaculaires et on commence avec le
pire des stars à la fashion week paula
nous en a déjà nous on a déjà dit
quelque chose regardez tout de suite
les jeunes
et maman m'a prise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
montaigne où zahia ne pouvait pas monter
les marches de mort sa robe était serré
et kim kardashian s'est emmêlé dans ses
bottes pour respirer pour transpirer
comment elle fait
possible de transpirer c'est très
spécial on va continuer avec le best-of
des défilés les défilés les plus
originaux on va dire
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est d'être vu qu'on ne verra jamais
nulle part après chaque big boss de
l'argent foutu en l'air non
sélectionné c'est comme ça que tout le
monde applaudit que personne n'achète
que personne ne va porter cession de
l'expression artistique
georges tron on va se dire ça on
continue avec une parodie de l'humoriste
maxim castle sa relation avec de paris
qui vient de s'achever justement
donc il ya plus de limite pas de souci
ok
[Musique]
soit
comme
[Musique]
ça et on termine ce top avec un
classique les plus belles chutes
la tête
[Musique]
kenney
[Applaudissements]
la dernière c'est au ralenti avec les
plates formes incroyables effectivement
les transports on est triste pour cette
colère qu'elle va bien mais c'est aussi
ça quand même on a fait